[Applause]
what's up guys we are from phoenix we
can't be more excited to be launching
our very own table dance racket the
punctuative senses
and to celebrate the launch we have made
an exclusive edition of 100 numbered
rackets
and today we'll be gluing and trying
them out ourselves
so for example if you are the fifth
person to make an order you'll get this
number five rackets so be fast
let's start off with the first two
rackets
this is the one the world's most
valuable pong rocket
this is the number one let's start
gluing
the glueing has begun this is gonna be a
long day
yes let it dry
[Music]
so the first ever pongfinity racket
being cut
[Music]
voila that is the first red rubber
there number one
[Music]
yeah edge tape
that's ready the world's first
pongfinity
racket good touch good touch
[Music]
feels good in the hand let's test them
out
oh let's try try one backhand
okay see how this works i have no idea
oh okay okay
it works or does it yeah
it's okay it's okay
[Applause]
around the net oh there we have it it
works
[Applause]
i mean not bad number one racket
number one always number one always
number two
you were number two in that rally but
for the racket it has
really good control and a good spin so
it's suitable for
any developing player one out of
100 the very first racket
who will get this pause the video go
quickly to pongfinity.store and buy it
and then come back and watch it number
one
in a few years this might actually be
worth something yeah it's pretty close
it's like a collectible item whoever
gets this
send us a message the first package done
so racket number one
[Music]
and two we need to be shipped to the
world
two percent done 98 to go
i like glowing table tennis rubbers
[Music]
racket number four i'll give it a magic
kiss
no nobody wants it anymore
[Applause]
perfect yeah
[Music]
racket number three half long somebody's
gonna get a broken racket
that was dodgy
[Music]
pass the half long check number three
and four we are
progressing now we're gonna speed things
up we're gonna do 10 rackets at a time
[Music]
it was about two and a half years ago
when we started thinking about making
our own racket
feels super exciting to actually get
this launched now and
and have everything ready
[Music]
okay so the racket number six gets
six forehand loops really
let's pack it up but you should have got
five blocks
actually you did get five
[Music]
[Applause]
whoever gets number 10 they'll have a
secret signature under
[Music]
otto's vibing with racket number 13
13. my favorite number no wonder you had
good wipes
number 13 gets a cartwheel
very suitable for cartwheel shots this
one
this is gonna take so long
it's 5 p.m currently and
i really can't see that we would be done
with this before midnight
19 is very good footwork thanks
[Music]
1.9 millimeter thick we have the ittf
approval so this is actually a rubber
that you can use
officially in any tournament
[Music]
i want eight of glowing thousands
rackets
we have four of the six already almost
100.
do you guys have any suggestions that we
could come up with these
let us know in the comments
authorized let's test these records
the first around the net
oh really good for our nets as well
50 okay that means we are halfway
through this whole process
and it's almost midnight
whoever gets number 50 you'll also get
a racket case pongfinity racket case so
you can keep your racket here
that's highly recommended to to get for
your racket very nice quality
very nice whoever gets number 50 you'll
get it
for free
51 is of course the number of the behind
the back shot
55 and 56 the phong infinity balance
challenge
oh that's nice one
very good one two
nice three
no 57
[Music]
i don't know why i twiddled it's past
midnight we've been glowing for
13 hours the remaining blades
and the remaining rubbers
let's do this
[Music]
we wanted to have the the colors of our
logo so that's where we went for black
and red
and we thought this looked really cool
with the black surface and
the red little stripe going through like
this the silver
lens looks so nice there yeah and then
also
underneath like the pongfinity text and
the logo
[Music]
are you gonna go home now yes nice
[Music]
you know it's quite funny like you can
already hear the bird is like starting
to sing outside
because it's 3am the birds are waking up
[Music]
we also have to thank like everybody who
has helped us with this
everything from from the design to uh to
the robbers and everything so
a big thanks to all of you who who have
been with us
making this possible and of course all
you viewers for
that's that's pretty much the whole
whole reason why this
at the first place is even possible that
we actually launched this
and it feels so so nice for ourselves
it's been
sort of like a dream for us to make a
known racket at some point
and to see it like concretely now ahead
of us
is really really cool so thank you for
that
this is the final one 100.
yeah i think we'll keep this one as a
memory of this
crazy idea it's surprising how much time
it actually takes
to make 100 rackets
98 99 100
done okay it's 4 00 am
we have the rackets ready we still need
to test the last 20.
[Music]
good or alternate with 84.
[Music]
oh
don't give me there so that was
almost 20 hours of making our own table
tennis racket what a crazy
project but we're really happy how it
turned out to be
and hope you enjoyed as much as we did
yeah
now it's time to go sleep and you go to
pumpkin in the store
get your records until next time